get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel is an awesome language learning
app they're one of our sponsors I use
Babel to improve my Italian and I'm
loving the results I'd recommend Babel
to anyone go check it out here's
something very interesting I'm not
actually sure what to make of it
Americans in every age group see Donald
Trump as a bigger threat to world peace
than other authoritarian leaders
including Kim jong-un Vladimir Putin Xi
Jingping
and Nicolas Maduro this is from YouGov
check out the numbers generation Z sees
Donald Trump is the biggest threat
followed very closely one point behind
by Kim jong-un
Millennials see Trump as a way bigger
threat than anybody else to world peace
28 percent say Trump's the biggest
threat Kim jong-un at 17 and Putin at 16
percent Generation X agrees Trump is the
biggest threat to world peace but only
by one point / Kim jong-un 25 to 24 then
you've got the baby boomers who see
Trump as the biggest threat just ahead
of Kim jong-un twenty seven to twenty
five I believe baby boomers start at
nineteen forty five and then you've got
the Silent Generation people born
between 1925 and 45 who see Trump as the
bigger threat and they see interesting
geopolitical differences they see she's
young ping as second twenty seven for
Trump and 22 for the Chinese leader
absolutely fascinating numbers and it
would be interesting to see numbers in
other countries as well on these same
five authoritarians now there's more
important implications here if Donald
Trump is the biggest impediment to world
peace this means by necessity by logic
that under trump the united states is an
impediment to world peace now that's
horrible for those of us who care about
world peace having our president seen as
the impediment to peace is sickening and
disturbing and disheartening but there's
another issue here and you're probably
already getting a sense of where i'm
going to go it's not just under trump
that the United States has played roles
geopolitically that have hindered World
Peace you can argue that the American
role I mean look I don't want to I don't
want to make it seem like I'm picking
the most important things but I'm just
mentioning a few things you can argue
that the American role in the nuclear
arms race has been counterproductive for
world peace you can point to American
intervention in Latin America over the
last many decades as running counter to
World Peace you can look at the United
States choosing to start numerous
military engagements over the last many
decades as obviously running counter to
World Peace the the truth is that the US
has made many decisions antithetical to
world peace through foreign policy for a
long time but in this particular point
in time
Americans correctly see Donald Trump as
an impediment to world peace the foreign
policy of the US has been problematic
for a long time we can say it's
cartoonishly more acute during the
presidency of Donald Trump now those who
believe that for example Vladimir Putin
is doing the puppeteering of Trump they
might see Putin as worse in that he's a
proxy to what Donald Trump is doing and
Trump is the one sort of checking the
boxes Donald Trump checks a lot of
authoritarian boxes you've got a
tyrannical megalomaniac bigot with
access to nuclear weapons no sense of
common sense or decency while
simultaneously lacking basic knowledge
about the world and even the most
fundamental critical thinking skills
that is a dangerous recipe and clearly
Americans ranging from Gen Z all the way
up to the Silent Generation agree it
seems the disagreement that exists is
how much more of a threat to world peace
is Donald Trump than other
authoritarians around the world and on
that issue people do actually seem to
buy divided by age and interestingly
older Americans seeing the number two
threat to world peace as Xi Jinping the
Chinese leader let me know what you
think about this make sure you're
following me on instagram at day
Hockman and while you're there follow
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show a ton of exclusive and
behind-the-scenes content regularly
appearing there